all right thanks so much for the call
really appreciate a little busy a little
bit yes all right take care
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number we are taking
your calls we are going to go next to
our caller from the three six zero area
code three six zero caller please
identify yourself tell us who you are
where you're calling from and feel free
to go right into your question today my
name is Andrew and I'm from Vancouver
right above Portland I live in
Washington I have to start off by saying
I love your show I'm so happy I'm
talking to you right now
so my question can that consignment to
if he wants to answer this Wow okay and
then I sort of have a second part of the
question how big of a fan are you of the
Star Wars franchise um I am I am a
moderate fan I mean honestly I go I go
to the movie so infrequently I genuinely
think the last movie I saw in the movie
theaters with Star Wars Episode seven
which at this point I think is a year
and a half old something like that I
like the Star Wars series I haven't
watched any of the ancillary stuff like
the cartoon one I've not watched rogue
one I've seen episodes 1 through 7 I
like 4 5 6 & 7 the best I thought that
the prequels 1 2 & 3 were not
particularly good Pat you want to chime
in on that you're gonna think I'm a
disgrace a total disgrace I've never
seen Star Wars that's one of the
episodes okay that's fine okay well so
Andrew what's part two of the question
he's driving and paid over there
but two part two part two of the
question are you guys familiar with
audible yes the audiobook service yes
there are some amazing source books on
there and I would highly recommend it
with you guys like fiction okay alright
alright well uh yeah Pat's Benson you've
been talking Pat about getting more into
audiobooks in general right although I
think with Star Wars too you know so
talking about Star Wars alright
Andrew thanks very much we will take
that under advisement and report back if
there's any news but I do look forward
to episode eight that that I can tell
you for sure folks absolutely how
wonderful great ok thanks Andrew thanks
so much for the call the calls are
interesting today there's sort of an
interesting feel to the calls I would
say are you sensing that as well I
wonder if we're going to talk politics
at all today I know I do wonder